kerstin sander selbst im rollstuhl das
ist natürlich nicht schön
und als ob das nicht schon bereits genug
ist hat sie echt kein glück mit ihrer
krankenkasse
es klingt wie ein schlechter witz aber
die betriebskrankenkasse schwenningen
will ihr keine neuen rollstuhl reifen
bezahlen weil ihre rollstuhl 4 km h zu
schnell fährt dabei hat sie sogar das
okay bekommen von der krankenkasse ihn
schneller zu machen erfährt jetzt statt
6 km h 10 km h über die krankenkasse
weigert sich nach wie vor das zu
bezahlen
doch es gibt jetzt ein happy end und
zwar beim spar fox hat sich ein
zuschauer gemeldet und hat jetzt die
reifen bezahlt wir haben jetzt aber in
der leitung thomas förster herr förster
hören sie uns sie sitzen im auto sie
haben diesen fall bei uns gelesen und er
hat sie sehr berührt was möchten sie
frau zander sagen meine frau carmen und
ich will gleichen es bis sie aus
schicken sonst die rechnungen wir zahlen
ihnen eure ihre neuen reifen für ihren
rollstuhl
ich hab selber an guten freund er hat
die gleiche krankheit wie schon seit
jahrzehnten
ich weiß wie schwierig des pc ist und
ich hoffe wir können ihnen dabei ein
stück helfen fahnder was sagen sie
ich bin kein statt also ich denke das
ist in den fragen sind tatsächlich hat
sich herr forster bei uns gemeldet und
wir dachten uns wir sorgen mal ein
bisschen für überraschungen herr förster
auch ihn
vielen dank und 500 euro ist ja auch
nicht wenig und es findet toll dass sie
da so viel mitgefühl haben und ich
glaube die frau zander fühlt sich oder
frau zander fühlt sich dabei sehr gut da
[Musik]